au niveau de la gouvernance locale
d'abord dire que oui le maire de
montréal et à coop 21 mai la présidente
de l'union des municipalités main de
suzanne roy et tous y a comme 21 tous et
à paris avec madame st-hilaire de de
longueuil on s'intéresse à ces travaux
là et je dois vous dire que toute la
démarche de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre à l'union des municipalités
on y travaille depuis certainement une
dizaine d'années les actions les
changements dans les municipalités se
sont amorcées il ya déjà une dizaine
d'années à l'époque où on a commencé à
faire l'inventaire des sources de
production de gaz à effet de serre
issues des démarches municipal du
fonctionnement municipal
on a identifié les flops municipal et
les camions les voitures comme étant une
des sources importantes et déjà depuis
une dizaine d'années des actions étaient
prises dans chacune des municipalités
on peut retrouver même dans les petites
municipalités des voitures électriques
on peut retrouver des camions qui sont
approvisionnées ou alimentées au gaz
propane donc ces changements ont déjà
commencé à se faire dans chacune des
municipalités dont le cpo dia qu'on y
pense deuxièmement d'autres actions qui
ont été prises la gestion des la gestion
des eaux pluviales
on a changé aussi si vous allez dans les
villes
vous allez vous apercevoir que de moins
en moins il y aura des stationnements
avec des surfaces d'asphalt sans rien y
voir sans rien voir d'arbres sans rien
voir de de 10 lots de 10 lots très cher
pour contrer les îlots de chaleur des
modifications au niveau de la gestion de
nos infrastructures
c'est changer aussi on gère bon je vous
disais qu'on gère les eaux pluviales
mais finalement on s'est arrêtés depuis
plusieurs années de grossir la
tuyauterie pour éventuellement récupérer
la totalité des eaux de surface partout
et récupérer les mêlées dans certains
cas aux eaux domestiques
donc là il ya des actions concrètes on
est engagé dans le processus de
recyclage des matières des matières
résiduelles
on est engagés actuellement dans le
processus de collecte des débats tia
biodégradables on s'est engagé depuis
plusieurs années je le répète dans une
démarche alors peu importe les objectifs
qui vont être fixés et peu importe que
le ce que le canada ou même québec
décidera en termes d'objectifs on est
déjà dans ce processus là et on n'a pas
pas d'atteindre ces objectifs là parce
qu'on est déjà en marche
je pense qu'à ce niveau là on peut se
féliciter des actions d'avoir été
prévenants et encore une fois je vous le
dis tout ce qui se décide atterri dans
les municipalités
tout ce qui est toutes ces grandes lois
qui vont être passées ces programmes qui
vont être mis en place vont atterrir
chez nous on est prêt à les recevoir et
même à les bonifier d'une certaine façon